Where did everybody go? Zombies. Rapture.
One big surprise party off the planet.
For whatever reason,
you are the last human on earth.
So what do you do? Eat like a king.
Move into Buckingham Palace. Drive fast.
Blow things up. Be naked all the time.
Or would you pretend you weren't alone?
How long would you last?
This is what if, and here's how you can
survive as the last person on earth.
So you wake up one day and find your
the only person left in the world.
Kind of cool, right? No
obligations, no rules, no limits.
Go nuts. Step one, enjoy the good things.
While you can go for
the exotic fruits first,
if your mangoes and bananas
are imported from overseas,
chances are there'll be hard to come by.
So eat them while you can
and enjoy every last bite
step to find a secure source of fuel.
You might think that with
no one's stopping you,
you could go anywhere but not so fast.
All those abandoned cars,
boats and planes you see lying around,
we'll be useless.
And about two years when their fuel goes
stale, guess he'll be sticking around.
But for how long?
Step three find a place to live.
If water, food, and shelter
are your basic needs,
shelter would be the easiest to come by.
You'd literally have a world
of homes to choose from,
but be careful where you settled down.
Cities will become dangerous
since without proper maintenance,
they'd start to fall apart pretty
quickly. Nature's elements, rain, frost,
and he would take their toll.
Rot and mold would become widespread and
vegetation would crack through concrete
and breakthrough glass.
But even if you were able to fight back
against nature's reclamation of the land,
all it takes is one bolt of lightening
to start a citywide fire and you can't
call the fire department, so
run for the hills. Step four,
get yourself some protection,
but even the country isn't all that safe.
First of all,
there are predators you'd need to
defend against wild dogs, feral cats,
bears,
but you'd only have to worry about them
as long as you could still breathe.
There are more than 400 nuclear
power plants in the world,
and once they're automated,
safety systems began to fail.
Without human supervision, there
would be meltdowns across the planet,
rendering many regions simply
uninhabitable. Step five,
find some food
in terms of food.
The city would be your best bet.
Supermarkets have enough canned and
frozen food to last you for decades,
whereas in the country,
crops and livestock would start to
dwindle without proper care or protection
from predators.
But if natural is more your style,
you'd have to go back to the old
ways of hunting with a spear or bow.
Since ammunition would be
limited and harder to come by,
maybe you could grow your
own little vegetable garden,
but that would cut into your
water resources. Step six,
it's all about the water.
Without other humans,
you'd be without electricity.
Water pumping stations and treatment works
with shutdown and the freshwater kept
in reservoirs would go
stale quite quickly.
You could rely on bottled water and you'd
probably have thousands of liters to
go through, but eventually you'd
have to learn how to purify your own.
Step seven,
start learning.
You don't have to teach yourself a
lot of things, but lucky for you,
you've got a lot of time on your hands
and millions of books out there with all
the information you'd need to
survive effectively on your own.
So while it might be hard at first,
you could technically survive
as the last human on earth,
but would you really want to,
humans evolve together as social
creatures in order to survive?
We joined forces against hunger and
harsh weather and build families and
communities to share stories, empathize
and keep each other happy and healthy.
Human contact has been scientifically
proven to build trust and reduce stress.
So while it's apt to cramp your style,
be glad it's a small world.
We need each other more than you think.